disney is often criticized for not
really caring about the parents at all
in case you haven't really noticed
almost every disney princess has either
lost both or at least one of their
parents from having multiple wives to
facing really terrible ptsd wait until
you see what happened to some of the
disney parents now let's check out what
happened to disney parents snow white's
parents we're starting with the one that
started it all snow white is the
ultimate princess that started the
disney princess legacy so you know we
have to give her credit we pretty much
know all there is to know about her
story you know the evil queen the apple
the mirror the dwarves and so on and on
snow white is a gentle creature often
criticized for her stereotypical ways
but not much is known about her parents
in fact they didn't even appear in the
original movie and weren't considered
significant in fact some of the biggest
disney fans seem to think that snow
white's parents have both passed away
but that's not really true you can
actually find the king aka her dad in
the 1979 musical adaptation of the movie
father snow white my dear you are a
vision in the musical the king is very
much alive and present throughout the
story in fact he loves snow white very
much the huntsman actually notifies him
of the evil queen's plan the musical
adaptation also follows the original
grim version of snow white which states
that her mom passed away during snow
white's childbirth according to the
musical her mom wanted nothing more than
to have a daughter with her skin as
white as snow and she definitely got her
wish cinderella's parents cinderella is
also one of those characters that had to
face a parentless life which of course
represents a huge part of her story but
there seems to be a few inconsistencies
in some of the earlier versions of the
cinderella story before disney got their
hands on them for example in charles
peralta version cinderella's dad is
actually still alive but unfortunately
he appears to be totally neglecting his
daughter lady tremaine is still quite
manipulative but so much so she has
total control of cinderella's dad this
means that cinders can't even complain
to her dad in private without lady
tremaine being all over them so it's
safe to say they are both held hostage
in that situation her mom is never
mentioned in the disney animated movie
but we learned that she passed away when
cinderella was 10 years old in
cinderella's royal wedding her mom has
dark brown hair and violet eyes but in
the live-action remake she has long
blonde hair and brown eyes in other
versions of the story cinderella's mom's
passing also had a really strong impact
over both cinderella and her dad the two
both witnessed her passing and
cinderella was told to be always kind
and courageous have courage and be kind
my darling she continued to share that
trait after her mother was gone while
her dad completely changed his loving
ways for the worse aurora's parents okay
so what about aurora she's one of the
few princesses that has both of her
parents alive except for the fact that
their stories are slightly different
depending on the version you read
aurora's mom is named queen leah and her
father's called king stefan in the
original disney movie version the two
are completely minor characters which to
be honest it's quite surprising for
parents that are actually monarchs but
since their daughter got cursed and was
taken away for 16 years to be raised by
fairies they really weren't in much of
the picture oh dear what an awkward
situation but what we do know is that
there is a happily ever after and the
parents even give aurora the keys to the
kingdom in the abc series once upon a
time queen leah doesn't really exist
well she does she's just called briar
rose and a bunch of complicated stuff
happens in between but we won't spoil it
all don't worry she unfortunately
eventually passes away and king stefan
doesn't really care all that much
because he's preoccupied with taking
revenge on maleficent that's it that's
all that happens and moving on ariel's
parents okay we all know about king
triton so let's focus on ariel's mother
athena she's not really that much
present in the original movie and of
course there's a reason for that it's
actually quite a tragic story
unfortunately ariel's mom passed away to
an unfortunate run-in with pirates when
ariel was just a baby this is precisely
the reason why king triton hates humans
which is a fair point actually but if
you want to learn more about athena's
story and her life you have to watch the
little mermaid ariel's beginning where
she's shown in the beginning of the
movie her life story is also explained
and we get just a little bit more
information about king triton's softer
side and the love he had for his wife
there's a music box involved too which
explains why king triton banned music
from the kingdom your father had the
music box made for your mother we all
know how much ariel loves to sing and
judging by her looks she's a spitting
image of her mother queen athena's story
also makes you really feel for king
triton because he looked like he really
loved his wife with all of his heart
belle's parents while belle's father is
present in the original movie her mother
is a complete mystery seriously she
isn't mentioned once if you want to find
out more information about her you have
to dig deep for example the 1993 musical
adaptation features a song called no
matter what where father marie sings
about her mom and suggests she was from
the upper class in the 1989 version of
the original screenplay of the movie
belle's mom was supposed to be mentioned
in more detail but she was later cut
during the final edit and once upon a
time she appears for a brief second and
is given the name colette unfortunately
she doesn't really make it out alive in
the 2017 live-action adaptation it is
revealed that she was a victim of a
terrible illness she told maurice to get
belle far away to escape the plague
which is why they moved to the small
village but still not much is known
about belle's mother and her life has
remained a mystery jasmine's parents
jasmine's parents real names are never
really revealed they just go by sultan
and sultana we know a little bit more
about the sultan who actually appears in
the movie since of course jafar wants to
overtake the kingdom sultan only
mentions jasmine's mom when he talks
about the fact that she wasn't as picky
as jasmine when it came to selecting a
suitor in a movie called disney princess
enchanted tales follow your dreams the
sultana owned an aggressive horse called
sahara okay sahara it's okay in the
original aladdin stories called tales
from agrabah we also learned that raja
the tiger got his name by a star
jasmine's mother would tell her daughter
stories about a tiger named raja the
original stories also claimed that the
sultana wrote a letter for jasmine which
was supposed to be read at her wedding
since jasmine loved her mother so much
she decided to model her own wedding
after her parents the sultan and sultana
were a definition of true love despite
the fact that their marriage was
arranged pocahontas's parents if you
thought belle's mother was a mystery
pocahontas mother is even more
mysterious seriously not much is known
about her at all but we do know that
pocahontas has her mother's spirit and
she goes wherever the wind takes her
chief pohatan is the only one that has
some backstory and even so it's not
really a lot all we know is that he's
very protective of his daughter and
doesn't really like the white settlers
at the beginning of course he later
changes his mind thanks to pocahontas
herself but what we do know is that
pocahontas is based on a real historical
figure and that bohoten is too and if
you look deep enough you can definitely
find some dirt on pocahontas's dad
according to the history having multiple
wives was totally allowed back in the
day as they symbolized wealth so
naturally poatin had about 100 wives as
well as several kids which might be why
pocahontas's mother never played a part
in the story mulan's parents mulan has
both of her parents alive and she's one
of the few with a consistent story we
see both folly who's her mother and fa
zoo in the movie mulan's parents seem to
really love each other and we can see
how sad fali is after she realizes her
husband wouldn't come back from more
alive mulan's father is also pretty
strict and he doesn't hold back to tell
his daughter about what's expected from
women during that era it's a completely
different world than today mulan's
parents story also remains consistent in
any other appearance they have but it's
usually always kept to a minimum it
looks like they really are one of the
few parents from our list that have a
clear history tiana's parents tiana's
parents are called eudora and james we
don't see james much due to his passing
but eudora is very present in the
princess and the frog eudora is the type
of mother every disney princess deserves
she's totally supportive of tiana's
dreams but she worries that her daughter
might be overworking herself in once
upon a time it is revealed that after
her husband's death queen eudora had to
auction items of her castle to pay her
taxes she also encourages tiana to marry
rich as that would solve her financial
issues not much is known about james
except for the fact that he fought in
world war ii he was actually the one
that gave tiana advice about working
hard in life which of course she's taken
very seriously you gotta help along with
some hard work of your own he was a
simple man you just enjoyed loving his
family and didn't need any material
things to make him happy rapunzel's
parents just to be clear we're talking
about queen ariana and king frederick
the og parents and not mother gothel
entangled before ever after ariana
reveals that she felt lost in the world
and had no idea what she wanted to do
with her life she was an adventurer who
was always somewhere in action and ready
to help people in every series she
appears in she remains a supportive
motherly figure however king frederick's
story is a little bit different
entangled before ever after it is
revealed that frederick became super
paranoid after the kidnapping even after
rapunzel returned he could never come
back to his loving father role instead
he feared for rapunzel's life and
restricted her from pretty much anything
to forbid you from leaving the walls of
this kingdom without my consent father
both his daughter and eugene compared
him to mother gothel as it looks like
rapunzel just went from one extreme to
the other he continued to be an
overbearing figure in rapunzel's life
his role is even more expanded in once
upon a time where it's very clear that
rapunzel's kidnapping left him paranoid
beyond repair merida's parents we've
seen the happily ever after in brave but
is that really how it ends in the movie
we're introduced to queen eleanor and
king fergus and once upon a time queen
eleanor is having some trouble raising
her kids she also appears to be pretty
busy ruling dunbroch and passing the
crown on to merida she's not really a
prominent figure and her story remains
to be quite stable but the story is
slightly different for king fergus it is
revealed that sometime after the events
of the brave movie take place dunbroch
is invaded we won't spoil it all for you
but let's just say that a witch is
involved and that king fergus doesn't
get a happy ending like at all but if it
wasn't for king fergus we'd never get to
see mulan teach merida how to properly
use a sword despite his fate it looks
like king fergus mellowed down after the
events of the original movie and really
accepted his daughter for who she is
anna and elsa there are plenty of
theories surrounding anna and elsa's
parents but if you want to know them all
you'll have to watch some of our other
videos of course anna and elsa are the
only unofficial princesses on our list
but we love them so much we just had to
add them in their names are king agnar
and queen iduna they're the typical
disney parents with the king being
slightly more aggressive and strict and
the queen more loving and once upon a
time we get to find out more details
about the pair and by the looks of it
queen eiduna had a sister who had the
exact same superpowers to make it even
worse she trapped her sister in the same
way elsa was kept locked away we also
learned that the queen left a letter for
anna and elsa explaining how wrong it
was that the two were left apart but
according to the story it took 35 years
for that letter to be found which is a
pretty long time either way we really
hope that elsa's mom learned her lesson
and that her own sister was able to
forgive her and that's it for our video
don't forget to subscribe to the things
for more feel good content thanks for
watching and see you next time
[Music]
you